all right family we've got quite the
treat for you today
we recently showed you the wholesome and
rhythmic way in which kindred
celebrate the holidays on our xbox
series x showcase but what you saw was
only
most of the trailer what we have for you
today is what we're calling the
princess cut with a very special guest
appearance so i suggest you stick around
we're also going to find out what you
get when you pre-order
the bloodlines 2 collectors edition
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
and joining me here in the studio today
is nikatali
lead producer at paradox interactive
hello everyone
and rachel leicher lead creative
designer at hard suit labs
hello now these guys have all the
gruesome details but let's start with
what is your favorite part of the
collector's edition nikki
that will be the leaf statue and that's
because she's my favorite character
but also since i lived in seattle for
six months
it's really good to have a map kept as a
memento
and it's quite a faithful recreation of
seattle as you can understand it exactly
cartoon fight they're very cool and
rachel what's your favorite part of the
collector's edition
i'm a big fan of that seven inch vinyl
of the uh the original soundtrack
it's a really stunning physical copy
of that of the really really amazing
soundtrack
uh made partially by rick schaefer
composer from the original game so i'm
pretty excited to throw that on my
turntable
i don't think you'll be the only one any
bloodlines fan have
that theme stuck in their head we've
teased it enough it's time to find out
which kindred survive those los angeles
nights
and the long long road to seattle
[Music]
[Music]
there we go
[Music]
[Music]
move in the back of your head's gonna be
so full of phosphorus
it'll be a war crime
that's right everybody damsel is back
for bloodlines too
we are so excited to be able to announce
this that we have that she has returned
for our game
uh she has spent her time in california
since the first
game uh establishing the anarch free
state there and now she's on her way to
the pacific northwest just to
to spread that good good anarch word
uh bruja and annak i can almost feel the
rabble's blood rising
where's the justicar when you need one
but okay clang critique aside one of the
great things about damsel that old fans
loved was the
voice actress yeah that was courtney
taylor and she is reprising her role as
damsel which is super exciting
okay good to hear i won't be forced to
flashcraft anybody's voicebox into
anybody else
but is there anything else that you guys
would like to share with the viewers
about bloodlines too
rachel well we're just really excited
for people to start playing the game
and kind of find out what kind of
monster you're going to become
you can make all kinds of choices in
this game you can do all kinds of things
you can
glide across rooftops you can use your
powers of vampiric persuasion to get
what you want out of people
you can even dance your way into certain
people's hearts
if that is what you would like to do um
there are
many ways to be a vampire in in this
game uh
of course the right answer is to be a
bruja because we have cool jackets and
our pros at ravelrousing
okay there you have it the one defining
feature of brouha
is their 80s fashion sense and thanks
for joining us via link rachel and
thanks for coming into the studio nikki
that was rachel leicker and nikatali
from the bloodlines 2 team
thank you sir seriously that trailer
really creeps me out it gets me every
time
but i can't believe that damsel is in
the game